We now have a dynamic
programming algorithm
that's going to be able to reconstruct
ancestral states in binary trees.
But this algorithm assumes that
the structure of the tree was given.
For example, here was an optimal solution
to the small parsimony problem for our
toy multiple alignment of four species,
if we're dealing with unrooted trees.
But it assumes that chimp and
human are neighbors and that seal and
whale are neighbors.
It seems unlikely, but
there's nothing preventing chimp and
seal from being neighbors instead.
We need to find the smallest parsimonious
score for this unrooted tree as well,
which is 11.
We also need to find the smallest
parsimonious score for
the tree in which chimp and whale are
neighbors, where that score is also 11.
Now I'll have you note that when applying
our algorithm for small parsimony,
we're going to allow an internal edge
to have weight 0, as shown here.
Because if we were to compress
this edge, then we would no
longer have a binary tree.
So this brings us to
the large parsimony problem
in which we must find an assignment
of ancestral states to internal nodes
over all possible unrooted
binary tree structures.
As you might guess,
this problem is NP-Complete.
So, let's design a greedy heuristic for
this problem.
First, I want you to think about removing
an internal edge of an unrooted binary
tree, i.e.,
an edge that connects two internal nodes
along with the nodes that it connects.
So for example,
if we delete the edge connecting a and
b here along with the nodes a and
b themselves, then we can see that
we have disconnected this unrooted,
binary tree into four, disjoint subtrees,
that I'll denote W, X, Y, and Z.
There are three ways to then rearrange
these four subtrees around that internal
edge that connected a and b.
So the operation in which we move
from one of these trees to the other
is called a "nearest neighbor interchange"
for this internal edge connecting a and b.
To test your knowledge of this operation,
you might like to implement a program
that returns the two nearest neighbors of
a given unrooted binary tree with
respect to a given internal edge.
This program will then be used for the
"nearest neighbor interchange heuristic" for
the large parsimony problem,
which begins with an arbitrary unrooted
binary tree, then performs all possible
nearest neighbor interchanges over every
possible internal edge of the tree,
then solving the small parsimony
problem for each such unrooted tree.
Now, if we find a tree whose minimum
parsimony score improves over the current
tree that we have, then we set the current
tree equal to this tree, and we iterate.
Otherwise, we can't improve on the current
tree via a nearest neighbor interchange,
and we simply return the current tree.
Try implementing this greedy
heuristic yourself before we move on
to the final section of this chapter.